while the pandemic forces many of us to
stay apart two college students found a
unique way to bring people together they
started a matchmaking website of sorts
to help people socialize only instead of
looking for a partner it's for people
who are looking for a friend the website
called quarantine buddy already has more
than 30,000 users from 127 different
countries
Errol Barnett spoke with to quarantine
buddies who got more from the website
than they could have imagined a lot of
days a lot of nights have been difficult
by myself my mom now I'm having Pam just
stare by my side it's just been and it's
wonders for me 21 year old Sheldon Brown
is often home alone in Chappaqua New
York with his mother treating kovat 19
patients silverstein is a 77 year old
widow living alone in downtown Ithaca
New York an unlikely pair brought
together at the height of the pandemic
through a website called quarantine
buddies very simple application and
Sheldon was my first quarantine buddy
and my favorite and even though they
were rules that after week you can get a
new quarantine buddy I just stood with
Sheldon hey now share views on just
about anything relationships do you date
at all safety when you play golf today
Sheldon did you have to be in a separate
car and even milestones
[Music]
Pam is helping Sheldon find an
internship and even sent his mother a
face shield to use in the hospital my
mom she's very sensitive and she gets
very emotional very often so when she
saw that she was like wow and she said
there's great people out there it's
exactly why college students am Brickman
and Jordan Gold's wide developed the
site we're just kind of felt empowered
to help and like we needed to do our car
and that was in the form of helping
people to feel less isolated with
everything going on the site is centered
around a questionnaire matching people
with similar interests some bond over
music dance or just shared experiences
virtual hangouts are hosted each week
happy hours discussions cooking classes
you name it even though the country is
still opening up and and states are
opening out people are still signing up
for the website connections like the one
fall between Pam and Sheldon I'm not
looking at what colors Sheldon is and
he's not looking at what color I am or
what color any of us so we're we're
human beings were in the same race and
let's make this world a better place
something we always talked about about
how we can make things better and how
everyone should be felt equal this is my
grandson this is somebody I'm proud of
and I want to be with for the rest of my
life so that's what quarantine buddy
gives you a virtual grandmother just one
possibility in our new socially distant
world for CBS this morning
Errol Barnett New York yes ma'am that is
what you want to see I like these are
pockets of sunshine I call them you know
good things happen to good people even
in the midst of this pain yeah well you
know we have an epidemic in this country
I think we also have an epidemic of
loneliness but that is alleviating it we
appreciate it
well done quarantine buddy